smith's pharmacy is now joining several
other health organizations in offering
the covid vaccine seniors can now
schedule an appointment
to receive the moderna vaccine 8 news
now reporter kate houston went to the
pharmacy to break down the
vaccination process for those 70 years
of age and older
smith's pharmacy is calling this a
monumental day they hope by having
locations in different neighborhoods it
will make it that much easier for
elderly community members to get the
vaccine
as part of a statewide initiative
smith's pharmacy is administering the
moderna vaccine at 45 different
locations
so we're halfway there 50 percent
protected
in addition to being convenient the
pharmacy says it also allows individuals
to get vaccinated at any location
with open appointments rose kellogg
lives in the northwest valley
but scheduled her appointment at the
pharmacy on decatur and flamingo
i'm really happy to be able to do it
because we haven't been able to really
visit with
anybody family friends and canceled
trips down to
visit our kids down in houston so this
would be nice
pharmacies are given about 100 doses of
the vaccine per week
which will allow them to balance their
prescription volume while still
vaccinating a good amount of people
rosie barrientos took her mother and
grandmother to the pharmacy on wednesday
morning
they were one of the first to receive
the vaccine my grandma
recently did have clovid and she was in
the hospital for
a whole month and so
this was a way to prevent it and not to
go back to the hospital to receive the
vaccine an appointment must be made on
the smith's website
the pharmacy says it opens appointments
week by week based on how many vaccines
it receives once vaccinated
individuals will need to stay at the
pharmacy for 15 to 30 minutes for
observation
kate houston 8 news now we are still
getting a lot of emails and calls into
our newsroom on the vaccine how to make
an appointment what we've done and
compiled all that information you need
on when and where to get it right on the
front page of 8newsnow.com